MORE.
WE'RE AT CPAC.
TONIGHT'S BREAKING NEWS
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
♪
>> ON THIS STAGE ON CPAC ON
FRIDAY.
YOU ALL HAPPY TO SEE THE
PRESIDENT?
HE IS COMING TO SEE YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
HE HAS A LOT OF
ACCOMPLISHMENTS TO TALK
ABOUT NOW, OF COURSE, THESE
ARE ALL THINGS THAT THE
DESTROY TRUMP MEDIA NEVER
REPORTS ON BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T FIT THEIR NARRATIVE.
THEY ARE SINGULARLY FOCUSED
ON ONE THING NOT TRUTH
EVIDENCE AND THE FACTS.
IT'S ABOUT HOW TO TEAR DOWN
THIS PRESIDENT BY ANY MEANS
NECESSARY THAT'S WHY THEY
WILL NEVER TELL YOU UNDER
PRESIDENT TRUMP THIS IS ONE
YEAR UNEMPLOYMENT IN AMERICA
17 YEAR LOW.
AFRICAN-AMERICAN HISPANIC
UNEMPLOYMENT HAVE ALSO
REACHED RECORD LOWS NOW
UNDER ONE YEAR OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
THANK YOU.
JOBLESS CLAIMS ARE AT A
45-YEAR LOW.
AND SINCE THE ELECTION,
2.5 MILLION NEW JOBS HAVE
BEEN CREATED.
AND THERE ARE 2 MILLION
FEWER AMERICANS ON FOOD
STAMPS IN THE COUNTRY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
WHY HAVE CONSUMER CONFIDENCE
NEAR 17-YEAR LIE.
BUSINESS CONFIDENCE REACHED
LEVELS NOT SEEN SINCE
PRESIDENT REAGAN.
ALL OF THAT IS BEFORE THE
PRESIDENT'S HISTORIC TAX
CUTS HAVE EVEN STARTED TO
KICK IN.
90% OF AMERICANS ARE
EXPECTED TO SEE BIGGER
PAYCHECKS.
3 MILLION MORE AMERICANS
HAVE RECEIVED BONUSES.
OH, BY THE WAY, THOSE
BONUSES THAT THE DEMOCRATS
LIKE NANCY PELOSI, THEY ARE
CALLING THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
IN BONUSES CRUMBS.
IT'S A CRUMB IF YOU ARE
100-MILLION-DOLLAR NET
WEALTH PERSON LIKE NANCY
PELOSI.
ARE THOSE CRUMBS?
I DON'T THINK THAT'S A
CRUMB.
>> NO.
>> Sean: NO.
ALL RIGHT.
ALSO ON THE ECONOMY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS REVERSING
WHAT WAS A PRECIPITOUS
DECLINE THAT WE WITNESSED
UNDER EIGHT DISASTROUS YEARS
OF FAILED OBAMA POLICIES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS CUTTING
REGULATION AT AN HISTORIC
RATE.
WE'RE ELIMINATING 16 FOR
EVERY NEW REGULATION ENACTED
LOOK WHAT IT'S DONE FOR THE
ENERGY SECTOR ALONE.
ISIS HAS BEEN CRUREND CRUSHED
BECAUSE HE HAS ALLOWED THE
MILITARY TO DO THEIR JOB.
WE ARE NOW REBUILDING THE
MILITARY.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU.
AND THE PRESIDENT IS
DEMANDING THAT THE BORDER
WALL BE BUILT IN ANY
IMMIGRATION LEGISLATION.
NOW, IF THE DEMOCRAT HAD
ACCOMPLISHED HALF OF WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS AT THIS
POINT IN THEIR PRESIDENCY,
THE LIBERAL MEDIA WOULD BE
TRYING TO PUT THIS
INDIVIDUAL ON MOUNT
RUSHMORE.
THEY WANT OBAMA ON MOUNT
IN SPITE OF HIS FAILURE.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE THOSE IN
THE MEDIA IN THIS COUNTRY,
THAT'S NOT HOW THEY OPERATE.
NOW, FOR OVER A YEAR, THE
NEWS MEDIA INCLUDING
NEWS MEDIA CNCLUDING
NEWS MEDIA COLLUDING WITH
LIBERALS.
THEY HAVE BEEN SO FAR A
HOAX, A CONSPIRACY, A
FABRICATION.
THAT IS THEY CREATED ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP AND
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION EVEN
THOUGH THE MEDIA KNOWS THERE
IS NO EVIDENCE TO PROVE ANY
OF THIS IS TRUE AFTER NEARLY
18 MONTHS.
THERE IS ZERO EVIDENCE, BUT,
YET, LOOK AT THE DISGRACEFUL
COVERAGE YOU GET EVERY
SINGLE NIGHT FROM YOUR
SO-CALLED MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
>> A DIZZYING 24 HOURS IN
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
NO LONGER JUST INCHING
TOWARD THE PRESIDENT.
THIS MORNING, IT IS MORE
LIKE CAREENING.
>> I THINK THIS IS A
POTENTIALLY MORE DANGEROUS
SITUATION THAN WATERGATE.
WE ARE AT A VERY DANGEROUS
MOMENT.
THAT'S BECAUSE WE ARE
LOOKING AT THE POSSIBILITY
THAT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THOSE
AROUND HIM DURING AN
ELECTION CAMPAIGN COLLUDED
WITH A HOSTILE FOREIGN POWER
TO UNDERMINE THE BASIS OF
OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS AFRAID, A
POLITICAL HURRICANE IS OUT
THERE AT SEA FOR HIM.
WE WILL CALL IT HURRICANE
WLADIMIR IF YOU WILL.
THE WHOLE RUSSIA THING.
>> THIS IS EVIDENCE OF
WILLINGNESS TO COMMIT
COLLUSION.
>> THERE IS OUTRIGHT
TREASON.
THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT
WHAT IS HE DOING IS GIVING
AID AND COMFORT TO THE
ENEMY.
>> FREEMAN SAID THE ELECTION
HACK SOMETHING AT THE
CALIBER OF A PEARL HARBOR OF
A 9/11.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT.
>> I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH
THAT.
>> DONALD TRUMP NOW SITS AT
THE THRESHOLD OF
IMPEACHMENT.
[CROWD BOOS]
>> Sean: UM-HUH.
IT JUST SHOWS YOU THE PEOPLE
IN THE MEDIA ARE NOTHING BUT
LIARS AND FRAUDS.
AND BY THE WAY, THEY ARE
REALLY JUST AN EXTENSION OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
BY THE WAY SPEAKING OF
LIBERAL DEMOCRATS, THEY HAVE
BEEN IN LOCK STEP WITH THE
MEDIA.
YOU WILL NOTICE THEY ALL SAY
THE SAME THING.
THEY PARROT EACH OTHER.
THEIR FAKE, PHONY TALKING
POINTS AND THEIR LITTLE
BUBBLE.
SO YOU HAVE HAD DEMOCRATS,
THE MEDIA OVER A YEAR
PUSHING A MADE UP FALSE
NARRATIVE ABOUT SO-CALLED
COLLUSION BUT NOW IT'S ALL
BEGINNING TO START BOOMER
BOOMERANGING BACK AS I
PREDICTED AT THE BEGINNING
OF THIS YEAR.
EVERYTHING ACCUSED DONALD
TRUMP OF IN HIS CAMPAIGN
WITH RUSSIA IS EXACTLY WHAT
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE DNC
AND FUSION GPS AND
CHRISTOPHER STEELE ARE ALL
GUILTY OF.
AND PEOPLE SHOULD GO TO JAIL
AND LIKELY WILL GO TO JAIL
OVER ALL OF THIS.
[APPLAUSE]
AND THAT IS THE REAL RUSSIA
COLLUSION STORY.
AND UNLIKE THE MEDIA'S FAKE
NEWS NARRATIVE, WE HAVE REAL
CON VETO INCONTROVERTIBLE
EVIDENCE OF REAL CRIME AND
WRONGDOING.
LET'S LOOK AT THE PHONY
DOSSIER.
HILLARY CLINTON AND D.C.
PAID OVER 12,000 PLUS
DOLLARS.
I THOUGHT FOREIGNERS WEREN'T
SUPPOSED TO INFLUENCE OUR
ELECTIONS.
ANYWAY, TO CREATE A
COMPLETELY UNVERIFIED
DOSSIER THAT USED GOVERNMENT
LIES AND SOURCES.
AND STEELE WHO HATES DONALD
TRUMP.
DIDN'T WANT HIM TO WIN THE
ELECTION, THEN BRIEFS THE
MEDIA OUTLETS LIKE THE "NEW
YORK TIMES," "THE WASHINGTON
POST," YAHOO NEWS, THE NEW
YORKER, FAKE NEWS, THE WHOLE
NETWORK, CNN AND THEY TRY TO
INFLUENCE THE ELECTION AND
MANIPULATE THE AMERICAN
VOTERS AND FUSION GPS, THEIR
CO-FOUNDER GLENN SIMPSON
TESTIFIED THAT THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN AND DNC WEREN'T
AWARE OF ALL OF THIS MEDIA
OUTREACH.
NOW THAT SOUNDS AN AWFUL LOT
LIKE THAT THEY WERE USING A
PHONY RUSSIAN NARRATIVE,
PHONY RUSSIAN INFORMATION
THAT THEY BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR.
TO INFLUENCE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND TO WIN THE
ELECTION THAT WAY.
AND THEN ON TOP OF THAT YOU
HAVE GOT STEELE MEETING WITH
THE FBI, STEELE GIVING THEM
INFORMATION.
AND WE NOW KNOW FROM TWO
G.O.P. MEMOS THAT THAT
DOSSIER WAS USED TO LIE TO A
FISA COURT JUDGE ALL IN AN
EFFORT TO GET A WARRANT TO
SPY ON A TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATE AND THE CAMPAIGN.
THAT, OF COURSE, BEING
CARTER PAGE.
THE MEMOS ARE ALSO EXPOSING
HOW FORMER FBI DIRECTOR
ANDREW MCCABE, HE TESTIFIED
WITHOUT THE DOSSIER, THE
APPLICATION FOR THAT WARRANT
WOULD NEVER HAVE EVEN BEEN
APPLIED FOR.
CERTAINLY NOT APPROVED.
AND WE KNOW FROM THE
GRASSLEY GRAHAM MEMO THAT
THE BULK OF THAT APPLICATION
CONSISTED OF HILLARY
CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND PAID
FOR DOSSIER.
NOW, REMEMBER, THIS IS THE
DOSSIER THAT JAMES COMEY
TESTIFIED UNDER OATH WAS
SALACIOUS AND UNVERIFIED.
THE FBI AND FUSION GPS.
THEY NEVER BOTHERED EVEN
BEGAN TO CORROBORATE THIS.
AND THEN YOU HAD COMEY,
REMEMBER BACK IN JANUARY OF
2017, BRIEFING THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT BEFORE HE IS
INAUGURATED ABOUT HOW THE
DOSSIER EXISTED.
AND HE SAID IT WAS
UNVERIFIED AND SALACIOUS.
NOW, THAT WAS ONLY MONTHS
BEFORE WHEN HE IN 2016 IN
OCTOBER, WELL, HE WAS --
THAT DOSSIER WAS THAT
UNVERIFIED WAS GOOD ENOUGH
TO USE AS A JUSTIFICATION TO
SPY ON CARTER PAGE:  THIS IS
WHAT WE CALL DEEP STATE IN
ACTION.
THIS SUN ELECTED.
OBAMA HOLDOVER BUREAUCRATS.
THEY THOUGHT THEY KNEW
BETTER THAN YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
ABOUT WHO SHOULD BE THE NEXT
WITH
PRTH
PRESIDENT AND MAKE NO
MISTAKE ABOUT THIS.
THE DEEP STATE TRIED TO
PREVENT DONALD TRUMP FROM
BECOMING PRESIDENT AND NOW
THEY ARE DOING EVERYTHING
THEY CAN POSSIBLY DO TO
DAMAGE AND DESTROY HIS
PRESIDENCY.
AND AT ONE POINT, REMEMBER
AT THE BEGINNING OF HIS
ADMINISTRATION, OVER 125
LEAKS AND 126 DAYS.
NOW, HERE'S THE THING ABOUT
ALL OF THIS.
THE CORRUPT OFFICIALS ARE
ALL NOW BEING EXPOSED.
THEY NEVER THOUGHT THIS
WOULD HAPPEN.
EVERYTHING IS BOOMERANGING
BACK ON THEM.
AS WE LIKE TO SAY ON OUR
TWITTER ACCOUNT TICK TOCK.
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN REPORTING
ON FOR THE PAST YEAR IS ONLY
A SMALL SAMPLE OF WHAT IS
COMING.
WE EXPECT THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S REPORT TO HAVE A
LOT OF NEW INFORMATION AND